it's a three-day visit by the French
President they'll be talking about lots
of trade and economic issues inevitably
but the subtext is clearly around the
the war in Ukraine macron's made no
secret over the last few months he's
been regularly calling President Putin
uh keeping lines of diplomatic relations
open even though he's attracted quite a
lot of criticism for doing that because
he recognizes that eventually the war
will have to be brought to close and
it'll be diplomatic efforts that do that
and he's trying to do the same with Xi
Jinping um he's urging China to use its
influence to try to break a piece in
this war
so why is Asia Wonderland there
yeah he's not been traveling Alone um
but interesting that macron will know
that his doesn't matter what he says he
won't change the political calculus of
China but um by being accompanied by us
of underlying who's been very critical
of China particularly on uh their very
close Without Limits relationship um
with Ukraine with between China and
Russia and um she's been using really
robust language since he's even been
using some of that today
um she's reminded though China of its
obligations as opponent member of the
U.N security Council which is all about
peace and security but it's also evident
from China's language that actually they
are trying desperately not to take sides
in this conflict they're not for the war
they keep reiterating not providing
weapons they clearly want to keep
themselves a degree of neutrality in
this war yeah a degree of neutrality but
from your understanding it Xi Jinping
and China what is their standpoint with
Ukraine because they're playing friends
to Ukraine as well as Russia like you
said trying to tread that line of
neutrality so how does all of what we're
seeing unfold behind us tie in with
what's happening in Ukraine yeah it's
it's a complex map and with the we'll
try and weave that together but
zielinski has been visiting Poland and
one of the things that came out during
that polish visit was the first time
that one of his advisors said that if
the spring offensive if Ukraine spring
offensive is effective then Ukraine will
be willing to talk to Russia about uh
Crimea now it's the first time
previously president xlitzi's been
really firm we're not going to have any
talks unless Russia's completely out of
the donbass and completely out of Crimea
so it's a real softening of the language
and particularly the West that's always
said militarily it'd be really difficult
for Ukraine to actually evict Russia out
of Crimea the timing of this is think is
also though interesting
um the ukrainians are softening their
language President Putin has revised his
aims he seems revoking now on the
donbass and securing um Crimea China
wants to remain neutral because it
doesn't want to see Russia fail but it
also doesn't want to see this war
escalate and actually if you look at the
three superpowers Russia American China
Russia and America are deeply embroiled
in this battle China is the only one
that can and it would almost certainly
suit its Global stasis to be seen as a
peacemaker very early days planets have
got to align a long way but we are
starting to see the faint first
movements of the potential for talks
maybe later on this year